aujourd'hui on parle du honor 8x le
nouveau smartphone milieu de gamme
milieu cas milieu de gamme entrée de
gamme entre l'entrée et le milieu
williams qui a été présentée par au nord
il ya quelques jours alors ce honoré 8x
fait plusieurs promesses
on va les détails et les unes après les
autres on va regarder au final si ces
eaux dans 8 x est plutôt intéressant oui
ou non si on peut se positionner là
dessus on voit qu au nord à une
profondeur de gamme qui est complètement
hallucinante il y avait le 7,6 l'année
dernière il ya eu un vrai vrai vrai vrai
bel effort qui fait du point de vue
design tout ça on va le détail est rien
[Musique]
bon sur ce honorio ticks il ya quatre
promesses essentiel la première c'est le
grand écran multimédia sans bordures
lumineux un design qui est vraiment
repenser ce qui est vraiment intéressant
c'est à dire d'avoir une petite encoche
sur le dessus quasiment pas de menton
donc c'est à dire quasiment pas de
bordures en bas un design bord à bord un
écran qui occuperait 91% de la face
avant est aussi une protection anti
lumières bleues vous avez donc un écran
full view 19 points 5/9 6,5 pouces fhd
plus avec une définition de 2340 par
1080 pixels alors l'idée de honor là tu
sais qu'il tient dans la main comme un
smartphone de 5,5 pouces et pourtant il
ya un format 6,5 pouces je vous présente
à côté d'un autre smartphone 6,5 pouces
du marché c'est l'iphone 10 s max alors
l'idée c'est pas du tout comparé ces
deux smartphones parce que
fondamentalement c'est pas du tout la
même chose par contre ce qui est
intéressant c'est le format on est
vraiment quasiment sur le même format
ludique c'est un petit peu plus grand
que l'iphone 10 s max l'épaisseur sas
vos emplois kif-kif mais surtout vous
voyez qu'on est dans koch qui est
beaucoup plus petite que celle de
l'iphone 10 s max on a un menton qui est
légèrement plus grand sur l'honneur 8x
par contre là on est à 1300 euros et là
on est à 2 165 euros
donc franchement en termes de design on
les compare pas un je suis pas là pour
les comparer mais juste pour
effectivement vous mettre deux écrans de
5,5 pouces dans l'actualité côte à côte
voilà en tout cas on va vraiment que
pour le tarif de ce point de vue en tout
cas il n'ya vraiment pas à rougir
on peut se demander pourquoi ce que au
nord a choisi d'avoir un écran de 6 5
pouces et qui au final est assez grand
alors assez grand oui non et qui a quand
même relativement main dans la main on
est pas mal mais l'idée les
constructeurs aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
faire un focus ion de multimédia c'est à
dire que dans les usages on voit
qu'effectivement on consomme énormément
de vidéos sur youtube sur les différents
réseaux sociaux est donc d'offrir une
vraie grande belle qualité de visionnage
et une expérience toujours plus sympa
l'idée de honor là dessus c'est de
cibler des personnes qui veulent avoir
une expérience multimédia une expérience
de visionnage de youtube absolument
incroyable et vous le voyez avec un
écran de 6,5 pouces est vraiment bien
alors à la différence d'un iphone 10
lorsque vous allez par exemple sur
youtube et vous allez zou mais vous
n'allez pas voir ici une petite partie
renier au niveau de l'encoche son
préféré faire de choix au niveau
logiciel
vous arrêtez et d'avoir une image qui
absolument pas rogner on a par contre si
des petits coins arrondis de tous les
côtés c'est relativement sympa respecte
vous regardez des vidéos c'est hyper
agréable
alors après d'un point de vue audio il
ya quand même du son
[Applaudissements]
quand on parle l'expérience multimédia
il ya effectivement leçon qu'on peut
écouter avec son haut parleur mono ici
bon c'est bien ça fonctionne s'il ya
beaucoup de bruit autour c'est pas donc
l'extraordinaire par contre point très
positif des choses conserver ici la
prise jack
ce qui fait que vous pouvez brancher
votre casque de dons pour tous les
amoureux de jack
croyez moi qu'il en reste encore un
paquet alors reconnaissance faciale
aussi hein ça marche très très bien hop
voilà ça des verrous très rapidement
vous pouvez le développement et la
reconnaissance faciale peu les lauriers
avec le capteur d'empreintes digitales
faire votre chemaf à votre code enfin
comme vous voulez dans tous les cas ça
marche extrêmement bien
bon ils sont plutôt pas mal ça
fonctionne plutôt bien
je trouve que en tout cas ce qui est
vraiment intéressant avec ce smartphone
est il vraiment le focus que fait
honneur là dessus c'est vraiment se
donner une expérience de visionnage
vraiment de qualité
le son est pas mal avec le parleur mono
avec le cas ça fonctionne très bien
donc ce point de vue là c'est plutôt
bien réussis dont ils ont aussi fait un
focus en nous annonçant un smartphone
qui fonctionnerait plutôt pas mal en
conditions de forte luminosité bonne
luminosité
bon là c'est le cas on est à paris à
regarder fait beau il fait chaud on est
quasiment à la mi octobre ces
commandites et tout va bien donc ce
qu'on va faire
celle que on va checker et on va
regarder si en conditions de bonne
luminosité on arrive quand même à y voir
quelque chose là le smartphone est
déverrouillé
je vérifie j'ai poussé la luminosité je
suis à fond de 6 à fond mais bon voilà
là c'est vrai que on n'y voit pas grand
chose alors vous vous rendez pas compte
à la caméra bon je vois un peu mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas l'expérience la
plus dingue plus d'avoir là dessus alors
il ya beaucoup de soleil là je cherche
un petit peu délibérément le elle pousse
un peu dans ses retranchements
je vois quand je mets face à moi je vois
quand même quelque chose je vois un peu
ce qui se passe mais c'est vrai que
c'est pas là où il va être complètement
le plus dingue toujours à l'extérieur
mais pour coup je me suis mis à l'ombre
alors luminosité toujours pousse à fond
ou jours n'étaient pas contents les
caméramans en tout cas de ce que je vois
ça me convient vraiment bien
l'expérience est cool donc voilà ça
fonctionne
alors je vous dis lorsque vous êtes
vraiment plein plein plein soleil on
sait pas forcément le meilleur
par contre là ça va ça va ça fonctionne
c'est pas mal forcément si vous le
mettez en pleine luminosité
vous cherchez un petit peu l utiliser
dans ses moindres retranchements parce
que on est quand même sur un smartphone
qui coûte en version 4 gigas de ram son
casier de stockage 249 euros
et si vous le prenez en 4 gigas de ram
et 128 giga de stockage il coûtera 299
euros donc forcément si vous le mettez
tout de suite en plein soleil s'est pas
non plus complètement idéal par contre
pour l'ensemble des usages que vous
allez avoir en intérieur même en
extérieur mais pas forcément met en face
au soleil il va extrêmement bien marché
donc pour moi en tout cas la promesse
faite par honda dessus sur un qualité
d'écran qui est vraiment bien en tout
cas surtout par rapport aux tarifs par
rapport aux techno qu'on a à l'intérieur
le fait d'avoir une expérience
multimédia qui vraiment bien pour moi le
dessus la promesse est tenue
bravo nord deuxième promesse qu'elle
fait sur ces honneurs 8x c'est la
puissance et notamment avec le soc kirin
710 couplé au gpu turbo ou alors on est
très clairement pas sur les derniers
stocks de silicone on n'est pas sur un
kirin 980 non plus sur à kirin 970
centre d'un côté un peu trop technique
c'est pas là qu'on va voir le regain de
puissance néanmoins néanmoins ça marche
très bien pour utilisation standard poor
je dirais que 90% de ce sont des choses
que vous allez faire pour regarder des
vidéos pour limer ligne pour des réseaux
sociaux pour publier des photos pour
faire des photos ça marchera très bien
et pour gaming parce qu'on sait que au
nord a vraiment au coeur de cible un
public assez jeune
addict aux jeux donc l'idée
effectivement c'est de pouvoir proposer
une solution pour pouvoir jouer vraiment
agréable vous allez pouvoir jouer à un
jeu du real et 80 85 % peut-être 90% des
jeux du marché
si vous avoir des choses qui vont être
extrêmement gourmandes ça peut être un
peu compliqué pour ça il va falloir
monter sur des smartphones un peu plus
puissant dans la gamme de chez au nord
notamment sur le honneur 10 par contre
par contre vous allez pouvoir jouer à
plein de jeux sans aucun problème et
c'est ce qu'on va faire maintenant vous
a déjà quelques petits jeux qui sont
installés d'origine csn ce cri de spider
man qui nous donne moi peu importe qu'on
va se faire un petit jeu de voiture on
va jouer asphalte nitro voyez là
l'expérience typiquement là dessus c'est
assez fluide alors je ne suis pas encore
champion de ce jeu là voilà il reste
faire une petite virée
pas mal à les bouges aulas a donc là
typiquement pour des jeux comme celui là
c'est très très très très très agréable
là l'expérience de jeu est vraiment cool
en terme de gameplay c'est pas non plus
hyper hyper hyper compliqué les voiliers
par contre c'est vraiment hyper fluide
ça fonctionne très très bien ça répond
tout de suite et c'est vraiment hyper
hyper hyper hyper agréable champion du
monde
voyez tout moi là dessus pour faire
tourner un peu une belle j'ai tout de
suite à l'installation il reconnaît en
qualité graphique moyenne j'ai quelques
petits ralentissements dont pas très
gênant c'est vraiment du point de détail
de trois petites rues bon c'est pas bien
grave
ça me permet quand même de jouer alors
apprécié je suis face à des mecs hyper
hyper hyper surentraînés ça peut être un
petit peu problématique mais bon voilà
c'est vraiment du coin de détails sinon
l'expérience est quand même relativement
c'est fluide
la promesse est là dessus en terme de
jeu d'expérience de jeu de puissance par
au nord est tenu nous annonce un an 8 x
75 % plus puissant que léonore celtics
effectivement le gpu turbo qui jouent
derrière pour ça mais c'est vrai que
pour du gaming pour utilisation pour
tout ce que vous voulez vous serez pas
déçu pour moi la deuxième promesse là
dessus aussi est tenu par contient punch
est encore un petit peu dubitatif c'est
le cadre des smarties choc c'est ce
qu'ils ont présenté cloneur play c'est à
dire que votre smartphone va vibrer
quand vous allez jouer c'est plutôt cool
et autres est sur le papier assez
intéressant par contre lorsque je joue
je ressens aucune vibration du
smartphone jeu lorsque je vois un peu
légère je sais qu'avec les honneurs
plaît je vous avais montré dans ma
présentation lorsque j'étais directement
à berlin sur la presse il y avait
pourtant un gros partenariat avec paige
et donc on dit quand on joue à payer
j'ai le cadre des smart shox on va
l'avoir
je joue j'ai pas de vibrations du
smartphone valora s'il ya des choses en
particulier à faire au nord vous invite
à nous le dire parce que j'ai pas trouvé
j'étais fou dans les paramètres et voilà
je sais pas trop là je bloque un peu
surpoids après l'expérience de jeu reste
sympa mais c'est vrai qu' avoir cette
techno en tout cas l'avoir très
facilement facilement paramétrable ça
pourrait plutôt cool donc ça c'est un
petit peu le point un peu en deçà autre
point qui a été mis en avant par au nord
c'est l'autonomie avec une batterie 3750
millions terreur il nous annonce une
autonomie de un jour et demi alors c'est
vrai que en termes d'autonomie j'ai pas
du tout été déçus par le smartphone
j'ai utilisé plus d'une journée j'ai
joué j'ai fait des photos les réseaux
sociaux fait pas mal de choses là-dessus
et c'est vrai c'est vrai que ça
fonctionne plutôt bien alors
effectivement
la problématique aujourd'hui c'est que
comparer des fiches techniques par une
fiche technique ont un peu complexe on
peut se dire là dessus on a une batterie
3750 milan perd heures l'autre jour on a
présenté les google pixels 3 vous avez
une batterie de 2900 milliards perdre
mais nous annonce un neuf jours
d'autonomie
là on nous annonce un cinq jours
d'autonomie avec une baisse car plus
grosse donc on se dit comment avec une
batterie deux mille neuf cent millions
terreur on peut faire plus qu avec une
batterie de 3150 - terreur bon jour un
peu complexe par contre ce qui est sûr
c'est que l'optimisation logicielle est
hyper importante notamment là dessus
avec le gpu turbo qui va vraiment servir
à accroître la l'autonomie de ce
smartphone
il ya pas mal de petites choses qui un
briquet les unes avec les autres font
que l'autonomie est plutôt bonne en tout
cas sans parler chiffres sans parler
vraiment au top et techniques en termes
d'autonomie un jour et demi pour moi on
les tient donc ça aussi c'est plutôt
cool non plus jeter la troisième
promesses qui était fait part au nord
donc être lui aussi plutôt bravo
quatrième et dernière promesse qui pour
moi aussi un des points phares de
smartphones parce qu'on a beaucoup
d'utilisation en termes de multimédia
sas économie tout à l'heure mais un
autre point qui est très important je
dirais c'est deuxième point où peut-être
le premier c'est le côté photo vidéo
poteau double un traitement photo parce
que on passe beaucoup de temps sur les
réseaux sociaux photographier des
souvenirs qu'on partage ensuite avec nos
amis les constructeurs font vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de focus sur
la photo on l'a vu cette année avec la
maison-mère de honor c'est huawei avec
le pépin pro qui pour moi peut-être le
photophone de l'année avec le samsung
galaxy s 9 plus et note 9 qui sont
vraiment excellents là dessus et donc du
coup au nord se doit de faire honneur
justement à la photographie avec des
caméras boosté à l'intelligence
artificielle il vous le dis si à une
caméra parce que l'idée là-dessus
effectivement c'est d'avoir de la
reconnaissance de scène d'avoir un côté
logiciel complètement optimisé pour
avoir des photos magnifiques et même en
faible luminosité pour on va passer très
rapidement ce côté technique vous aviez
un double module 20 mégapixels + 2
mégapixels le 20 mégapixels une
ouverture de f 1.8 donc c'est à dire
lumineux en faible luminosité alors
pourquoi avoir 20 + 2
20 c'est vraiment jeté à la caméra
principale fournir chuté à voir des
photos de bonne qualité il le doit bien
travailler surtout pour la profondeur de
champ pour le mode sport trac les ailes
avant vous avez une caméra de 16
mégapixels qui annoncé comme étant
vraiment performante pour aborder selphy
d'excellente qualité alors la caméra à
l'avant elle sert aussi pour le
déverrouillage pour le fait seul bloc
qui marche très bien je les tester en
bonne luminosité en photo et vidéo est
en excellente luminosité ça marche très
très très bien le rendu est vraiment
super et là dessus on voit qu'il ya
vraiment très très beau travail qui est
fait par honneur pour ces honneurs 8x
est excellent en conditions de faible
luminosité
l'atypique moi j'ai soleil en pleine
tronche forcément le rendu est vraiment
bien en faible luminosité
il y aussi pas mal l'accord peut pas
trop lui en demander bon là on est au
staff là on est dans une école chez lego
et les séjours des caméras et on est en
train de jouer un nouveau jeu super bien
et je suis très mauvais voilà donc on va
essayer de finir comme ça on teste la
can en plaçant la caméra avant la figure
dans 8 x comme ça on teste tous les jeux
les téléphones enfin total l'asie en
hiver alors là on a le jeu lego qui est
juste la mine derrière vous avez là les
enfants qui est piñata en autres joueurs
derrière et là on joue donc à super
vilains de lego d'ici super vilains de
lego nouveau jeu donc là on est plutôt
pas mal
il y à des bonbons il ya un jeu vidéo il
ya une ps4 pro il ya des manettes
autant vous dire qu'on est super heureux
pour tester le smartphone enfin le
luminosité trois collèges
on est au top là on l'a on est encore au
top et là derrière il y avait peut-être
connu ça va beaucoup je suis une tête
connue mais c'est ça alors là vraiment
je fais le test en même temps des eaux
non à 8x savaté jour n'a pas dé métier
facile quand même
[Musique]
trop de violence pour les enfants grève
batman tu veux pas rassuré le côté
violent dès son départ ça fonctionne
plutôt pas mal sur la vidéo bon voilà
après et ça manque de lumière ont
forcément même si ce film avec mon g5 et
pas beaucoup de lumière
forcément j'ai avoir du bruit aussi donc
on peut pas non plus cracher dans la
soupe on est sur un smartphone avant
autour de 250 euros
donc ils marchent plutôt très très très
bien pour son prime tracé plutôt cool à
noter que pour vos photos en faible
luminosité il ya un mode qui est dédié
c'est le mode clichés nocturne qui est
plutôt cool
vous pouvez avoir soir en automatique
soit ensuite ici vous pouvez venir faire
pas mal de réglages pour optimiser
complètement vos photos en fonction de
vos besoins de vos envies ça c'est bien
le rebond après vous avez d'autres modes
le mode ouverture vous et pouvoir ainsi
régler votre ouverture donc ça aussi
c'est cool
le mode portrait bien évidemment qui va
travailler le constate la caméra de 2
mégapixels pour vraiment bas à venir
faire le fameux flou d'arrière-plan vous
avez votre mode photos j'étais un petit
peu standard vous pouvez faire
effectivement de la vidéo ici préfinale
jusqu'en full hd 60 images par seconde
c'est franchement suffisant et vous avez
ensuite ici plein d'autres modes le mode
pro mode ralenti panorama tout ce que
vous voulez et ça c'est plutôt bien
et justement le mode ralenti parlons-en
pour la qualité du mode ralenti je suis
pas du tout convaincu parce que lorsque
vous allez faire un ralenti vous allez
appuyer là il va rechercher un objet en
mouvement
là par exemple il enregistre et ensuite
il va vous sortir votre ralenti sauf que
en réalité la qualité est globalement
pas terry lors je les fais en prenant la
main je me dis bon ben moi j'ai la main
qui bouge un peu forcément le rendu va
pas être génial génial si je vous montre
la up
la caisse qui fait il a vu le ralenti
donc maintenant rives ralenti mais c'est
tout flou regardez le détourage
s'étouffe ou s'étouffe loue la qualité
pas terrible alors je me suis dit bon
c'est parce que je le tiens la main mais
non là typiquement je n'ai pas tenu à la
main je les poser sur un pied pas
vraiment la stabilité et la up
qu'est ce qu'il fait il a pris ralenti
en prenant en main regardez comme c'est
fou le détail au niveau de la main de
l'homme
le poil c'est flou c'est pas terrible et
bon ensuite ça reste de l'image voilà
donc ça c'est un petit peu dommage et je
trouve que le mode ralenti là dessus il
s'est globalement pas grand chose ou
alors il vous faut des conditions
complètement optimale il faut le sûr
maîtriser et c'est pas hyper hyper
intuitif quatrième promesses cette part
au nord là dessus sur ceux au nord 8x
pour moi c'est aussi un point remporté
bravo au nord parce que l la photo la
vidéo fonctionne plutôt bien alors si on
veut vraiment de la qualité de ouf
en termes de photos vidéos en terme de
jeu en termes toutes les expériences moi
je vous invite tout de suite à aller sur
l'eau nordistes qui restent quand même
pour moi le top of the top pour
l'instant chez au nord d'un point de vue
design d'un point de vue performances je
le trouve vraiment excellent loria
l'onudi ce qui est aussi une petite bête
de compet qui fonctionne très très bien
mais je suis un peu moins fan du design
par contre je trouve que ceux au nord 8
x est vraiment bien dans sa catégorie
et si vous voulez un smartphone qui est
pas trop cher 250 euros je vous le dis
vous serez vraiment pas déçu grand écran
pour le multimédia qualité vidéo qui est
vraiment bien l'audio fonctionne plutôt
pas mal les performances sont vraiment
honorable vraiment correct le dessus
pour jouer à des jeux pour faire ce que
vous voulez vous serez absolument pas
déçu l'autonomie est excellente elle la
partie photo vidéo est vraiment bonne
donc ce smartphone pour toutes les
personnes qui veulent jouer de temps en
temps qui veulent partager sur les
réseaux qui veulent se faire plaisir
vous pouvez y aller sans aucun problème
petit point supplémentaire en plus il a
un design qui est vraiment sympa au
niveau du dos vous avez si une finition
aurora glace avec 15 couche de verre une
partie si qu'un peu plus ma thune party
en bas un peu plus brillantes côté sympa
en plus la prise en main est vraiment
bonne il tient très très très bien dans
la main pour voir vous avez un écran de
6 5 pouces vous peut le tenir à une main
et même venir ici pour taper des sms
s'écoule alors attention quand même sur
des écrans ce grand allemand on va venir
l'utiliser à demain pour taper ses
messages je vous invite néanmoins à
mettre une coque de protection à
l'organisme qui est inclus dans la boîte
pour ciel vous plaît pas trop et je vous
invite à en choisir une autre
de toute façon il faut forcément de
protéger ça peut tomber très très
facilement puis même si c'est un
smartphone qui coûte que entre
guillemets 249 euros et coûte quand même
249 euros
et puis c'est de l'argent du point de
vue de l'ouest on tourne sur un android
8 points avec la surcouche em 8.2 bon
plutôt pas mal
si vous connaissez pas eu à mu vous
n'avez pas de tiroirs d'applications sur
le bas c'est pas la peine d'aller le
chercher vous avez tous directement ici
ça fonctionne plutôt bien voilà il y à
des personnes qui aiment ya des
personnes qui est moins
moi je crois en tout cas c'est plutôt
pas mal à noter que vous avez une
recharge en micro usb vous avez un
bluetooth 4 points 2 il est dispo en
noir bien évidemment comme ça vous le
trouvez également en bleu et en rouge
alors le rouge pour l'instant on n'est
pas forcément distribué en france il
devrait arriver mais bon en tout cas
déjà comme ça en noir et en bleu
franchement sont juste magnifique et je
voulais dire en termes de tarifs il est
extrêmement bien placé 249 euros pour 64
giga 299 euros pour le 128 giga
franchement à ce prix là pour avoir
cette qualité là vous pouvez y aller les
yeux fermés
d'autant plus en terme de qualité au
nord c'est vraiment une marque qui est
vraiment vraiment vraiment bien il ya
des mises à jour de l'ouest enfin en
partant là dessus vous êtes tranquille
il faut savoir comme je vous le disais
au north appartient à huawei c'est une
filiale ont besoin de suite
on peut y aller les yeux fermés c'est
vraiment un smartphone qui est excellent
voilà aujourd'hui pour cette vidéo est
due aux normes 8x moi je suis plutôt
content plutôt emballés de smartphones
chose que au nord fait vraiment du
l'excellent boulouris bataille se bat
vraiment fort parce que la concurrence
au niveau des smartphones elle est
complètement dingue le marché au niveau
international est complètement saturé en
france il ya eu cette année une vraie
accélération avec l'arrivée des
différentes marques chinoises au nord
c'est déjà là l'année dernière ondée
xiaomi qui arrivait yao bo qui arrivait
enfin là et ça continue d'arriver alors
c'est vraiment bien pour le consommateur
parce que ça tire un petit peu tous les
tarifs vers le bas et pour certaines
autres marques ça continue à les tirer
vers le haut pour vraiment se
différencier en termes de gamme dont je
vous invite vous à me dire ce que vous
en pensez en commentaire est ce que vous
trouvez ce au nord 8 x plutôt cool
plutôt séduisant mark et moi tout ça
dites moi ce que vous en pensez que je
vous invite bien évidemment comme
d'habitude à vous abonner à rester alité
parce que l'on va parler toujours plus
de stars comme j'en ai plein à tester
j'en ai plein avec moi il ya des pièces
qui vont arriver va y avoir des vraies
belles découvertes à la semaine
prochaine on va partir découvrir le
huawei le maïs vins et mets et vins pro
on va aller les prendre en main on va
regarder un petit peu ce qu'ils disent
et puis elle testera ultérieurement donc
vous invite comme d'hab à vous abonner à
la clé d'ici là soyez sages j'embrasse
[Musique]
où